I can stop there that's sort of enough
the that's what the Silver's man days
that have to show you but I was I'm
thinking about something this morning
and another way of solving is the third
way and it gave me a problem
it came up with an answer I wasn't
expecting and so I thought maybe you'd
be interested in as well so I'm going to
show it to you three approaches are our
level one T results
number two auxilary angle after the
third one I'm going to call my identity
to see why in a second okay so if you've
got subheadings on each of these we can
all really underneath that so this is
this is number three
so the question of solving sine plus cos
right usually our strategy with these
kinds of questions is to bring it down
into something simple enough that I can
solve but with other techniques that I
know okay
so we've used with broad identities or
brought it down to one function but you
know this is not the only way that you
can bring it down to one function you
can solve it right to siding collars
they have this relationship with each
other um then you can turn signs into
cosines and cosines into science if you
squeeze it the right way okay so do you
remember based on the Pythagorean
identity sine squared plus cos squared
if I wanted to turn this Clause into
something in terms of sine what could I
turn it into do you remember we use this
one we would differentiate the inverse
trig function starts with a square root
and what's underneath one minus sine
squared remember that okay in truth it's
a it's plus or minus it's plus sometimes
for different domains of clauses and
negative sometimes now as you'll see in
a second it doesn't matter which one we
kick so let's just see what happens as
we approach this and submissively what
happens so I'm not sine X plus this
square root business now on the face of
it this looks good
okay because you know when we were doing
equations reducible to quadratics and
you have like sine squared plus cos
squared and you want everything in terms
of one kind of function and that this is
all terms one function right so this is
good so how can I simplify this what
would you suggest will be my next step
I'm eventually going to have to square
right but I don't think I should square
this slide why not
why is squaring this going to give me
problems yeah this square root is going
to give me it's going to hang around
even after I squared is left hand side
you're a squared plus B squared plus two
a big so that's a problem if you
remember we had this kind of issue with
the Waqas questions okay I'm you have
distance equations you've got a live one
so I'm going to move I'm actually going
to swap their places I'll move that one
over and I'm going to take the square
root over the other side that's
- okay now I'm in a position work and
square okay so what happens to my left
hand side I'll get sine squared minus 2
sine X plus 1 and then I've just got 1
minus sine squared here okay by the way
this is why you can see it didn't matter
whether I picked plus or minus the
square root because squared anyway okay
so no problem now
this is an equation reducible to a
quadratic right so I've got plus one of
both sides so let's get rid of it then
you're going to sign square here so I'll
kick it over the other side and this
should start looking familiar
very very similar to what we had before
right all right so we had tan of X 1/2
at this point I can still divide through
by 2 that's a bit chamber you guys get
the idea and then I can factorize right
sine X sine X minus 1 okay now at this
point everything is looking nice is
sweet the other rows are too hard
um and I haven't even had to muck around
with the domain because it's just zero
to plant sorry for the plenitude to 2pi
and I don't have some VX on to theory or
Xmas plan for so this is looking good
okay let's solve it you've got sine X be
equal to 0 or 1
okay so you break apart and you say when
is sine X equal to zero you to trigger
all sine X in the normal domain 0 to PI
and in the middle right because this is
what it looks like okay so add three
solutions here 1 2 3 so so far I've got
0 pi 2 pi
ok I need a new pearpod then you do the
other part of it sine X is equal to 1 ok
and that's an exact value that's ponzu
now at this point you might not raise
any questions if this is all you had
done ok but we've already solved this
question twice and something's gone
wrong hasn't it what's gone wrong
I am a net I'm an extra solution
this guy's sort of snuck in ok now sure
enough you can test all of these results
for instance if we come back to our
original equation okay and you put in PI
you put in what's my sine of PI sine of
pi is 0
and what's cos of Pi
that's why this one on a second
something's gone wrong so if you knew
okay something might be going on here
you could test that you could show up
sure enough pie is not a solution
my question to you is why why should it
I mean what was wrong what on our book
the algebra is okay um these solutions
are okay
so had an extra solution creepy em to
this approach where it didn't in the
previous two hmm examine a video these
suggestions one of my heart I have an
extra solution
I can some stuff out that's interesting
I did cancel stuff out but usually when
we cancel stuff out we get less
solutions no more right like if I gave
you this okay
and you cancel stuff out you divide you
might actually get one solution but
really there are two so cancelling
usually reduces the number of solutions
we have it doesn't add them that's a
good suggestion it does change the
resolutions for the wrong way any other
ideas I square okay so this line here
away this line I do a couple steps
why would square he give us problems
okay all right now
I was I was thinking at this morning
because I was really sort of banging my
head against the wall why I was there
and why I could show was wrong whereas
you know all the rest of solutions are
fine okay so maybe you can grill this
solution off put like Big Red Riding
over that this is not a good approach
and I'll justify why in a second